cerebral Aqueduct stenosis is the key
cause of obstructive hydrocephalus in
this case the cerebral Aqueduct becomes
narrowed which lead to fluid
accumulation in the lateral ventricles
this is the zoomed in view where you can
see the lateral third and the foot
ventricle the passageway between third
and the fourth ventricle is the cerebral
Aqueduct which gets blocked in this
disease this is the normal brain where
the ventricles are filled with
cerebrospinal fluid and the obstruct and
there is no obstruction in case of
cerebral Aqueduct stenosis there is an
obstructive
obstruction in the cerebral Aqueduct
which leads to hydrocephalus in the MRI
one can see the large ventricle lateral
ventricle large third ventricle and a
narrow or small forward ventricle and
the cerebral Aqueduct is closed it can
be treated with VP shunt which drains
the fluid from the ventricles to the
peritoneal cavity what's the full video
to know more